In a few hours time, Meng Wanzhou will find
out whether she'll be extradited to the United
States ... or set free.
Canada's arrest of one of the highest ranking
executives at Huawei has placed the country
in the middle of a complicated dipsute between
the U-S and China.
I can assure everyone that we are a country
of an independent judiciary and the appropriate
authorities took the decisions in this case
without any political involvement or interference
as must be the case.
But political involvement from WASHINGTON
is EXACTLY what many in China suspect is behind
Meng's arrest:
China's economy is becoming stronger and I
think the United States is unhappy about that
so they've done something to harm China's
interests.
I think Meng's arrest's could be related to
that.
Meng was reportedly arrested on the same day
that Chinese leader Xi JinPing dined with
US President Donald Trump at last weekend's
G20 summit in Argentina.
That meeting resulted in the announcement
of a 90-day truce in their trade dispute.
It is now appears to be on shakier ground
than ever.